[Music]
welcome to Google cloud next my name is
Miranda zere I am a product manager with
Google cloud and today I'll be speaking
to you about how you can use bigquery to
transform your organization into a
data-driven one I'm joined by four BC o
Blanco from vayan technology and he'll
be going into vines journey to the cloud
using bigquery so to kick things off and
exercise does anyone recognize what this
number means a hint it's something that
you would find in a school anywhere in
the world exactly I heard someone in the
back saying that it's the Dewey Decimal
System exactly what it is so let's break
that down bit by bit the leading zero is
a classifier for information the second
zero is for computing information
followed by data processing in computer
science
networking why didn't a networks
internet and our final conclusion data
science on the Google cloud platform the
title written by one of our steam
training team members now some of you if
you've walked into a library in any time
in the past 10 15 years you might have
recognized that and for the most part
it's a useful system it's a little bit
subject to human error and some manual
difficulties but it is very important
and powerful because it allows for
people like you and me to navigate the
treasure trove of information that a
library is and so that it doesn't belong
to just subject domain experts like
librarians but we live in a different
world today we live in the world of big
data estimates put the Library of
Congress at anywhere between 15 to 20
terabytes of data for a big data
patien we can rack up 15 to 20 terabytes
within days in some applications
sometimes hours and when you think about
a library that doubles in triples and
sizes overnight you have a vast amount
of problems one scaling infrastructure
it's not easy to find the space to house
all those books in all that information
and related to that it's finding the
specific people that can manage that
number that level of data and to do both
of those things while controlling costs
there's no trivial task during my time
on the Google cloud customer team I work
with many customers with various big
data implementations and what I realized
was while they would come to me very
often with the technology problem many
times it was really a change management
exercise that was required and during my
time I'd see three main art types of a
data-driven organization one you have
the data-driven organization that is
constantly pulled in different
directions this particular team is
reactive they don't necessarily have the
proper data infrastructure and they tend
to be really just a supporter of the
business intelligence organization the
second type is one that is fun but not
very productive
this tends to not have a very strong
relationship with the engineering and
product team which allows them to have
very limited product influence and seems
to be typically unfocused the best kind
of data science organization is one
where data science are treated as
thought leaders once where data
contributions are recognized and
celebrated but most importantly what I
want you to take away from this is the
fact that data is democratized and they
are investing in productivity
importantly when data is accessible and
universally a veil
to people within the organization it
makes that or dish is that much more
tied to data which as we can all agree
in this room it's typically a company's
most important asset which transition to
how do you do data infrastructure with
GCP we know that your data comes in all
shapes and sizes for your relational
needs we have cloud SQL you have cloud
spanner for your non relational needs we
have cloud BigTable cloud data store for
your document database needs but what
I'll be focusing on primarily today is
bigquery the crown jewel of our data
analytics platform bigquery
is Google cloud platforms enterprise
data warehouse solution fully managed
and serverless if you're used to
managing backups and working on disaster
recovery plans with your data warehouse
you no longer have to worry about that
because that is taken care of under the
hood if you need to run petabyte scale
data and run queries across multiple
tables that can now return within mere
seconds through a very convenient main
intuitive sequel interface if you need
to scale up using CPU ram and memory no
longer do you have to manage that that
is all again managed under the hood from
the Google engineering team and more and
more what we're seeing is our streaming
capabilities come uniform in terms of
streaming dashboards but as we know that
technology is really is half the problem
the real problem is again people and
change management and when we look at
enterprise users of data we see them in
multiple buckets small server being deep
learning researchers which number in the
tens of thousands machine learning
experts which is in the low millions
engineers which is another order of
magnitude higher the tens of millions
but the largest sliver of that our
business users business intelligence
folks
finance accounting sales all these
people are the biggest consumers of data
yet if we don't have data accessible to
them that data is no longer an asset so
the question is and the question I pose
to you is how do you turn technology not
into it not from a barrier into an
enabler and with that I'll give it to
Fabrizio to share vayan story thank you
everyone for coming let me jump into the
presentation so what is vine vine is an
advertising technology company that
delivers the right audiences across all
inventory performance and channels and
it's capable of measure its impact
online and offline the main piece of
technology we use to do that is the DSP
which stands for demand side platform
since I'm going to be talking about all
the data flows into the DSP ma as well
give you a quick primer about real-time
bidding and the technology behind it on
this picture you see two sides demand
side and the supply side that the band
side is the advertiser technology
ecosystem that vertes are use two of
them spend media dollar or to buy
inventory online and the main piece of
technology use its DSP we have one of
those on the left side you have the
supply side which is a technology
ecosystem a publisher use to monetize
their audiences or sell inventory online
and the main piece of technology uses
the SSP which stands for supply side
platform the way advertiser buy media
online in real-time is via RTP protocol
and that's how the SSP a DSP communicate
to each other to give an example a user
comes to a publisher publisher could be
an app a website a video channel audio
channel anything you can imagine the
goal of the publisher is to maximize the
revenue out of this opportunity the way
they do that is by auctioning off this
opportunity to multiple buyers at the
same time and that's where they use the
SSP the SSP is connected to multiple DSP
at the same time DSP will just leverage
the data they know about the user to
decide if they're willing to bid or not
it's a welcomed bid or much they willing
to bid and then if they win the auction
that's called an ad impression and the
advertiser gets to display the ad on the
publisher that happens billions of
billions of times a day
and
generates a lot of data each single
auction is - because within 50 200
milliseconds we're talking about very
complex at stack and a lot of data what
does he look in terms of data for bi and
DSP we process more than hundred billion
events on a daily basis those events
represent more than hundred terabytes of
data on a second we produce more than a
million events and each single event has
more than 700 other points so when I
talk about events I'm talking about is
RTB request bid solicitation as well as
impression clicks conversion anything
you can do with ads and how did we
manage to do that before bigquery I'm
talking about before 2014 so on the left
side with a custom ingest problem we
just all this raw level data into a dupe
it is at one it was entering inside the
dope we say enter the data where I was
echo system but wait is a grey box you
can see that the data what else echo
system and the way that the world of the
ecosystem was managed by the data what I
was team and that was a handful of
people that was servicing the entire
organization for any data needs and the
way they were processing the data was
through MapReduce big a knife on top of
a dupe and can data marts typically out
of this process would be pushed into
Netezza which is a physical MPP
appliance huge you can query a sequel
interface and the way the business would
access the data was through a business
intelligence tool tableau pointing to
the scan data Mart
anything outside those kinda DeMars who
need to go approve a process of variant
pressurization
so although this picture looks pretty
nice and looks like everything should be
working the reality is if I have to
reflect what was happening at the time
everything should have been on flame and
melting and the reason was we actually a
very hard time keeping up with the scale
of the business every day more and more
data coming in and more and more
requests coming in and there are two
sides here on the scaling issue one on
the adducts aisle and then it is aside
ya dupe side although relatively easily
we could scale a binding machine and
storage the business was unpredictable
it was very hard to predict what was
coming on tomorrow next weeks next year
and so we were struggling and compromise
between CPU and storage constantly and
of course spending time keeping the
classrom on the net either side was much
much harder to scale you just
to double up on the cluster and we're
talking about millions of dollars of
investment in early to say that were out
steam instead of being an enabler to the
organization not because of their fault
was actually a disabling factor and the
reason was eighty percent of their time
was spent maintaining infrastructure
maintaining the cluster making sure the
existing pipeline wouldn't break so long
story short early late 2013 beginning of
2014 we started looking at alternatives
we did a bunch of PLC's and big way was
the big winner for us by far we moved
every single piece of data into it we
never looked back to what's the best
decision we ever made the reason we
picked bigquery is twofold number one it
is a server less infrastructure meaning
it is a service to us we do it to worry
about scaling we don't need to worry
about tuning the second big reason is
you could create hundreds of terabytes
of data within seconds and minutes
versus before I would have taken hours
and days if the query ever came back to
start with so how does the architecture
look like now that we have the query
very much simplified compared to before
still we have a custom ingest problem to
push the row level data into bigquery
the data were a psycho system right now
it's only big we every single piece of
data is inside bigquery the data
warehouse team would process data by
leveraging all the API available from
bigquery to process and produce the same
kane data marts we used to produce
before and were pushed into bigquery and
the way the business were access data
was through tableau pointed to bigquery
at this time and then we another thing
that we did we gave access to the user
using bigquery native UI by giving
access to row level data to a bunch of
people with sequin knowledge what
happened is the amount of requests that
came to the data warehouse team added
energy in team skyrocketed because all
these people finally saw the richness of
the data that we had and then ever had
access to it all of a sudden they start
dreaming about these data products all
this stuff they wanted to build and long
story short we remove completely the
bottleneck of our infrastructure with
bigquery
but the new bottleneck was created which
was engineering resources because we
have an T some believable race car which
was bigquery and only few people
drive it to its potential and those were
people with engineering skills that's
when we decided to build a couple of
tools magazine go light with the goal of
empowering as many people as possible
within the organization to basically be
a data engineer like anybody else with
no engineering skills but without of
course just with secret knowledge that
could do everything on their own without
involving anybody else and that's where
magnet single I were born in 2015 and
now available on Google Marketplace as
of 2018
I'm going to give you a quick demo but
before I do that the new architecture
looks very similar than before there are
two main differences number one buttons
are your tools on top of bigquery are
now used for processing and accessing
the data another big difference I lost
earlier you don't see it but if you
remember previous two diagram there was
this gray box data warehouse that's gone
and the reason is gone is because to
fold the data warehouse engineers first
of all their job description is changed
and our software Aegina building the
Potence tool those team the system is
not servicing the organization in terms
of data needs anymore
second is we actually fully
decentralized or data warehouse and
there is no central point where requests
come in everybody can do everything they
want around it as long as they have
permission on a specific data set and
now I'm going to jump into the demo demo
number one on this demo right now I'm an
analyst I work for the client services
team and my clients that they speak
lines are the advertiser this advertiser
had been asking to get their data back
on a daily basis or whatever basically
their impression logs back in the reason
is they use with multiple platforms and
one aggregate everything in one place
and for that I decided to use magnets
because I'm very familiar with magnets
which is a workflow Automator
and I want to make it such a way that is
generic
such that I can use if a new client
comes in tomorrow and wants the same
thing I shouldn't be able to change
anything at the workflow should just run
before I jump into the automation part
of it I want to disk show you what the
data set looks like and for that I'm
using goal ID which is our data explorer
the the tool that you use to explore
your data sets be able to query interact
with a
specifically I'm gonna the data set I'm
talking about is the ad impression data
set this is an actual sample of actual
data so we're talking about 28 terabytes
of data and now 4.3 billion rows in
total you can see quickly double
clicking here I have a sense of all the
tables in here I can sort I can see the
size of each specific table the size and
then if I click on it I can see that
Goliath died does a very nice job on
grouping logically the data by year
month and day I came out over a specific
day I see exactly with the size of this
table if I click I can see the scheme on
my table and like I mentioned before we
have this more than 700 at the points
per single event and impression is an
event and I can show you here if I
expand my list you can see that we have
all this seminar those are basically all
columns in our table and for us was very
important to see that organize the way
we actually solid 8 which is objects
within objects another thing that was
important for us as well is to actually
see what the content looks like for
anyone that is trying to work on queries
around the data so we wanted to
represent the data as object as well the
moment you preview or use you create the
data as you can see I can see I can go
across my columns and see the content
and have quickly a glance of what each
single field value could be like and
specifically now since I'm going to be
talking about extracting log from the
impression tables and one important
field I'm going to be needing is the
advertiser ID which is the one I'm going
to apply the filter for that query
and since I said I'm gonna make this
thing very generic what I'm doing is
creating a table called advertiser to
extract this advertiser to extract as
two columns number one is telling me all
the advertiser ID they need the data
back which is the first column the
second column is telling me well
definitely all advertisers they don't
want the seven and the data points that
we have they just want to pick and
choose whatever fields they want from
the table and here I'm describing what
they are and now I'm going to jump into
Magnus which is how I'm going to create
this workflow to automate this extra
so the first word for is called parallel
extract and before jumping into specific
of the of the workflow you can see on
the top the name of the workflow the
description the owner I can set up a
lifetime of a workflow and more
importantly I can schedule it as a crown
fixed or advanced as a con job and then
you can specify a time set a time zone
as well for T specific workflow on the
right you'll see very important element
here which are what we call parameters
and parameter are too kind built-in and
custom built-in is things that the
system generates for you magazaria for
you are typically time and date base and
custom is anything you want to create
thing about variable and constant and
your programming language that you use
to make your content dynamic and create
business all around it I'm going to show
you how I use these parameters so the
first task I'm using right now by the
way you can create as several tasks and
you put them sequentially and that
describes the workflow my first task is
a loop task as a loop task it requires
an input table this table I'm
referencing it via this variable and
this variable is the table I just showed
you before and which was a true Potence
which is one that describes the
advertiser at the end and their fields
and then it needs a parameter which is
called in this case advertiser which is
gonna iterate over and pull a row for
per table every time a trait disabled
I'm gonna pull a row and this this
record is this variable is of type
record and you can see here the way it
looks it's basically the scheme of the
table advertiser ID and the string which
is the field
another thing inside this loop I have
only one task which is a big query task
and what this thing does is just running
a query but as you can see there are
dynamic elements inside the query which
is the table itself and one extract the
data from I'm using this variable then
the filter itself which is the first
element of the record which represent
the advertiser ID and this is the fields
that they need out of this
the query and then another thing I
wanted to do is make the output of the
table generic and want to post fix yeah
at the tables with the advertiser ID and
the data and processing with another
thing that is was very important for my
client is to get the data as soon as
possible so what I wanted to do is
typically you have a workflow that ran
sequentially and sequentially because
our specific test depends on the
previous task well this specific case I
really don't need things sequential
because every single put is independent
of each other through Michaels I can
check simply say grantees as
synchronously and make them all run at
the same time to maximize time and then
at the end of the loop that you just
simply wait for all of them to finish I
can set up a time out I can I can get a
notification in case there was any error
so now I'm gonna run this query this
workflow by hand and the output of this
table should be will will show up inside
this data set right now is to still be
empty and while this workflow is running
I want to show you how you actually
check what's going on and you look at
the workflow history specifically for
this workflow you can see it is still
running the previous execution actually
finished so I'm clicking on this one and
you can see that the ten iteration got
submitted the loop has finished in 14
seconds all 10 quiz got some middle I
can drill down on any query and see what
was the quiz I got submitted you see the
macros got expanded for me you can see
as well how much data is scanning the
specific way and now you can check every
single one of them and then at the end
you see that is the weight task is
waiting for all of them to finish and
let's see if now it's finished so it's
not finished yet but the tabletops are
showing up here and I actually all of
them are finished now you can see the
ten advertisers are all done if I click
on here to see if it did what I was
supposed to do well for advertiser three
three one two I need the X ad times time
request URL and made all of them work
properly one thing I want to point out
okay I'm done with this specific demo
but one thing is it was relatively
simple to be with mangers
three steps really three tasks but if I
had to do this outside a magazine I
would have needed to ask an engineer to
build this software around it create a
bunch of threads push a bunch of jobs
out wait for them to finish in another
thread and then ask system engineers to
have a machine to run this thing on a
cron job worry about all this monitoring
all of that it is completely gone with
Mangus we don't need to worry Benny of
that in just managed transparently it's
a service on top of a service which is
bigquery so next example next example is
going to be a lot more sophisticated
example in this case we want to showcase
how you can connect Magnus with other
system via an API task because matters
can be initiated we manually or to a
cron job it can be called via API we can
trigger an execution on mangoes with a
bunch of GCP events but how do you
connect Magnus with external system
let's say with other GCP API or your
internal API well we have an API task of
course with the API task the world of
opportunity opens up and specifically
now I am a product manager I work for
the DSP and I have my advertiser have
been telling me lately that it takes too
long for my images creatives to be
approved and 3d text long is because we
have humans involved that check
physically if the image violates our
content policy and the support manager
have the idea well I know how to improve
this I would like to have my engineers
built this thing by engineers are always
busy so I decided to take it on my own
and the reason I decided to take it on
my own because I'm familiar with Magnus
and also I see that mine uses this API
tasks and a bunch of templates are
available to make it very easy to
connect to any API from the GCP
ecosystem including data flow pops up
Google Cloud Storage machine learning
which is I'm going to show you right now
etc so it's very very easy and you don't
need to worry about relation
authentication because the token gets
passed automatically by Magnus so at
that point I decide okay at school I can
do it I did some research on
Google vision API and they see they have
a specific API which is exactly what I
need which is a annotation API with a
safe search detection type of annotation
that takes in input an image and gives
me back if the image contains adult
content violent content racy content
medical content it's exactly what I need
so what I'm gonna do is just build this
Magnus workflow which is annotating you
creatives demo since it's a little more
complex compared to the previous one I'm
gonna give you a view because one of the
tasks for instance I'm using here is
calling a workflow so you can moralize
your code and create a bunch of tasks
within a workflow and then make other
people use it this case to show you the
entire view of what's going on here and
I'm showing you the tree view a thousand
feet level these are the name of the
tasks you can drill in on each one of
them but so what this process will do is
just check if on the creative table
there are any new creatives been pushed
if there are any new creative I'm gonna
call the classifier adds a workflow if
not I'm done there is no new creative to
to process so I finished the classified
ads workflow what it does is loops in
batch and batches the creative in input
just to make sure I don't want to call
one at the time I just want to batch as
many as the API allows me and then he is
the payload with this generate payload
in basically the API requires a JSON
payload I'm using bigquery to generate
this payload pass it to the API task and
then take the result back and on the
calling workflow I'm tracking here if
there was any creative that got flagged
if there were any pay that got flag I
sent an email out so I'm gonna execute
this and that should be receiving an
email shortly but what this thing is
executing I'm gonna give you a lot more
insight into the workflow so the first
workflow is what I just described before
I'm gonna chime checking if there are
any new creative to process and the way
I'm doing this is by leveraging the fact
that parameters are actually persisted
for Magnus so I'm using the
result of the previous execution to
check what was my last I did a got
processed and then I'm just using it as
a parameter on this quiz I take every
new creative since the last query ready
take the output and put it on this table
this table is described here he is out
input then what I do is count the number
of rows out of this query which is
specifically count the rows on this
table and assign it to this variable
which is new rows and then this is the
internal condition I check if there are
any new rows if it's greater than 0
pretty much go to the next test
otherwise finish because they have
nothing else to do the next but wait
this flashing means workflow finished
I'll show you the email soon the next
workflow which actually does the job of
classifying the as is as this
classifiers workflow workflow take
inputs and those are basically are the
parameters for the workflow which is the
destination table where this annotation
elite to be stored the source they will
the input to my API what our alt is
created I need to check the batch size
as well as the type of annotation that I
need to call the Google vision API word
and then I'm basically storing my ID for
the next iteration so I remember where
to start next time and then I'm checking
if any creative got flagged with a
sequel query let me go back here and I
should have received the email okay this
is a new email that just got sent as you
can see it's basically HTML table with
the first is the ID of the creator
second is the image like a annotated and
as you can see here these three images
have medical an annotation type of
there's a possibility there is medical
content status image and the same thing
for all three of them so it worked
meaning is able to detect there were
three creative possible medical content
by the way for the purpose of the demo I
just disable the check across at all
content and stuff just to avoid showing
something in the screen was not
appropriate as you can see here that's
you see the lines I Combinator out
this is just running the query is Jenny
my little HTML table that I am sending
vml yeah and there the email tasks and
simply say okay format as HTML this the
the other of the table and these are the
three roles you just saw which is
variable which is been computed by this
query and I'm going to show you by
clicking here what exactly does query
returned if I run this query you'll see
that the three rows were this one's it's
basically I'm showing an image and the
content and as you can see this cool it
shouldn't have shouldn't run because
dart is variables in here but guess what
when I click from mangoes and jump in
Google aisle all parameters that I need
to be able to execute the query being
brought over and I can show you the used
ones for the specific query where those
ones so I'm able to debug specific query
the way they are without changing them
so said that I want to show you how I
generated the payload from the
classifiers internal workflow this is
the execution the classified ads so I I
was batching the creative basing I'm I'm
using the limit and the offset of the
creative to batch through a bunch of
creatives and then I'm basically
generating the payload via a query you
will see what this query is this cool is
a symptom in it looks complicated by its
basic I'm generating a JSON object out
of three rows on a table and I can cut
and paste it so you'll see what the
output of this query is
this is the output of this table is
basically a payload for my API which is
a JSON representation of the images and
then if I look here
the next task that God executes is the
call of the annotation API what a passed
in input is this JSON that I prepare
with with the previous queries and
that's the output back so for educating
is telling me the probability of each
type of content and then the next task
I'm using javascript as - it's hard to
see sorry
to populate the the table itself and
take the result back so these again is
to showcase a little more complex use
case to be able to connect with several
api's but you can have microsensors
services internal to you and you can do
a similar thing one thing I want to show
you is now can you bring it back to the
presentation please to the slides yes
how do we use what are the stats of
potent with environment bind is not the
only case on vine build Potence but we
have multiple customers or proteins
those are stats only we didn't find
itself till today we are about 360 user
using the platform and by the way we
don't have that many engineers it's it's
all bi team research analytics team the
product people anyone you can imagine
using the tool those people generated
5000 workflow total number of tasks
across all workflow it's 180 thousand
you can see somebody went crazy and
build a workflow with 3200 tasks in it
so it must have been something complex
and but the average is about 36 probably
the minis median is much more than that
and then this is a current month the way
potencies used one of the 30 user used
Magnus those 130 user generated 600,000
workflow executions this workflow
execution generate 2 million queries
into bigquery and these two million
query process 16 petabytes of data
that's on a normal month was last month
if you're wondering our tasks are used
within Magnus well big way to no
surprise is the favorite task because
that's all workhorse where all the
things happening the big data crunching
is happening through Bitcoin the next
most popular task is go to task it does
make sense because you do business logic
through that if the if then else
conditions the workflow tasks is very
much used as well that's because you
want to modularize your your workflows
and you can have people build something
a little more complex like for instance
this classify ads and you as a user you
can leverage it by calling it as a
library then the API task is just to
connect with other systems and then the
script has to money play data and email
although is a small percent but is very
much used but of course you have one
email problem per workflow so that's why
it's only one one percent and that's it
for the presentation just go ahead and
try it put in say oh it is you can get a
limited use of Goliath and a trial of
Magnus we love it our customers love it
and it changed our life before we add
and full of people be able to do complex
things with data now you have hundreds
of people within an organization that
can do as much as eight engineers or
data whereas engineers could do without
involving people with engineers skills
thank you thank you for Bruce your brand
of applause
[Applause]
that was that was a live demo I was
actually watching him he did hit refresh
button a couple of times my heart was
racing that was probably the most
exciting thing I'll see at a cloud
conference um but with that what did I
highlight ignore Lucis speaking I wanna
highlight three big things that Vivian
did in this particular scenario one in
the first slide they showed that they
had a very very extended cloud footprint
and they said we no longer want to
manage infrastructure that was the first
step it's not no longer manage that
headache - they created an interface to
make data accessible to their entire
organization one of the more powerful
insights from that presentation was that
it no longer belonged to data scientists
it belonged to business users belonged
to all kinds of people that no longer
needed to work with the data scientist
and then three they're able to extend
the power of bigquery with the rest of
the Google cloud platform the most
powerful thing about that second demo
was that it was now using the machine
learning api's to basically generate
metadata to associate with creatives
instead of having to create a completely
different workflow in a completely
different application for customers to
access another part of the Google cloud
ecosystem this particular tool they
built was built all on top of that and
when I seen successful data companies
its companies that really bring the
power of different cloud technologies
all together in one place
so to summarize bigquery doesn't have to
be exclusively used by our data teams
again to think that it is that's only in
the domain of gimmick of data scientists
will be very short-sighted the real
power is when you unlock that power for
the rest of the organization when you
create tools like magnus or build your
own tools or with other partners and
then lastly bigquery is a flexible and
extensible platform one that allows you
to basically take its compute power and
apply it in many different scenarios I
don't know if you guys were paying
attention to the specific numbers that
were being generated but in the first
demo I saw that we know one iteration
was
through 300 gigabytes within the
10-second 1015 seconds and there was 10
queries being run in parallel that's
about 3 terabytes and again that data
does this that processing time doesn't
scale linearly it goes exponentially
faster and that is a very powerful
insight to take away to help bigquery
become the center point of your
data-driven organization to summarize I
want to also just kind of point you guys
to other really interesting
presentations we have a number of
customers they'll be presenting their
stories with bigquery and showing how
they use the power of it to enable their
organizations but a special focus on the
top line we have a spotlight session at
2:10 tomorrow afternoon this is where we
will be announcing all of the new magics
with bigquery and also across all our
entire detail analytics platform from
data flow to pub/sub to other new
products that we'll be announcing I'm
allowed not I'm not allowed to say
anything about it today or all
something's gonna lose my job but with
like you guys invite you guys to see
that tomorrow
[Music]